percent change if you want a formula way
of remembering it you can think of the
amount of change okay like you know what
it's changing by divided by the original
amount and this is the key a lot of
students will accidentally divide by the
new amount you want to divide by the
original amount okay because you want to
see how it's changing to compare to
where we're was before right okay now
another way to think about it sometimes
I just think about it this way my own
mind I just think it's the new - the old
divided by the old so just real simple
new minus old divided by old now let's
look at a couple examples we'll say
something's thirty dollars right and now
it's forty dollars now you can see that
it's increasing by ten dollars so we're
just gonna say ten dollars but compared
to what compared to forty or compared to
thirty compared to thirty right because
you want to see how it's changing a
period of how much it was originally
okay
now if we divide here 10/30 comes out to
0.33 three you know on and on repeating
so you can write this as a percent by
moving the decimal two places it's going
to be 33.3% like that okay
now the one thing that I like about this
form of the new minus old / old is we
would say okay the new amount is 40
minus the old amount which is 30 divided
by 30 and we can see that this is coming
out to a positive number so that means
that this is positive which means that
this is a thirty three point three
percent increase now a lot of students
will say well that's kind of obvious we
went from thirty to forty but sometimes
it just helps when you're doing this if
you get a negative number that'll
trigger in your mind Oh negative that's
going down it's decreasing okay so let's
go to the next example 100 280 so here
we'll just use my example here our new
minus old over old so we've got the new
amount 80 minus the old amount which is
a hundred divided by the old amount
which is a hundred so you can see this
is coming out to a negative 20 over 100
that negative just tells me that it's
going to be a decrease okay and if I
divide these you can see I'm getting at
0.2 zero which is 20% so it's a 20%
decrease and you want to write that in
when you do your problems you know
such-and-such percent increase or
such-and-such a percent decrease and
again you can either look at the
original amount you can see it's going
down here you can see it's going up so
that'll take care of that part or if you
just want to do the new minus old over
old Pazza means you know going up and
negative means you know decreasing going
down so I hope this helped you to
understand how to work percent change
better subscribe to the channel check
out some of my other videos on Mario's
math tutor and YouTube channel I look
forward to seeing the future videos I'll
talk to you soon